LATEST BIDEN STUMBLES IN WHICH
CLASSIC MOVIES DOES THE MOB WANT
SANITIZED?
THAT IS ALL AHEAD OF HIM UP AT
FIRST PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED A
STERN WARNING TO ANYONE PLANNING
TO STIR UP TROUBLE AT HIS RALLY
IN TULSA TOMORROW TWEETING TODAY
"ANY PROTESTERS, ANARCHIST,
AGITATORS, LOOTERS OR LOW LIVES
WHO ARE GOING TO OKLAHOMA,
PLEASE UNDERSTAND, YOU WILL NOT
BE TREATED LIKE YOU HAVE IN
NEW YORK OR MINNEAPOLIS OR
SEATTLE.
IT WILL BE A MUCH DIFFERENT
SCENE" THAT TWEET AFTER
CONCERNED THAT VIOLENT
DEMONSTRATORS WOULD BLANKET
THE CITY ORIGINALLY, TULSA
MAYOR WITH A CIVIL EMERGENCY AND
INSTITUTED 10:00 P.M. CURFEW
AROUND THE RALLY VENUE.
BUT LATE THIS AFTERNOON THAT WAS
APPARENTLY RESCINDED SO TRUMP
FANS COULD CONTINUE TO WAIT IN
LINE.
EITHER WAY, THE NEXT 24 HOURS
AND BEYOND ARE GOING TO BE
RATHER EVENTFUL.
MY NEXT GUEST HAS CONSULTED WITH
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ON HOW TO DEAL
WITH ANARCHIST GROUPS APPEAR
THAT SOUNDS LIKE FUN.
HE SAYS THE MAYOR IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO PREPARE FOR POTENTIAL
CHAOS.
CHRIS IS THE FORMER ASSISTANT
FBI DIRECTOR THAT JOINS ME NOW.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> CLEARLY AT THIS POINT WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW DO YOU
HANDLE ANTIFA OR ANARCHISTS,
WHAT SHOULD THE CITY AND
CAMPAIGN BE PLANNING FOR?
>> THEY SHOULD PLAN FOR THE
WORST AND WITH THE PUBLIC NEEDS
TO UNDERSTAND AND THOSE COMING
TO TULSA NEED TO UNDERSTAND IS
THE INNER FEDERAL PARAMETERS BY
THE SECRET SERVICE.
AND THEY MEAN BUSINESS.
THEY WILL PLAN FOR THE WORST.
THEY WILL HAVE MODERATE LEVEL
POLICE FORCE SHOWING, BUT THERE
WILL BE A LOT OF RESOURCES OUT
OF SIGHT AND IN THE BACKGROUND.
THEY ARE TRAINED TO DEAL WITH
THIS TYPE OF THING.
>> Tammy: THIS CLEARLY IS
WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT MATTERS.
THEY ARE TRAINED.
THEY KNOW GENERALLY WHAT TO
EXPECT, BUT IT WILL BE
INTERESTING, AMERICANS HAVE SEEN
CITIES THAT HAVE NOT TAKEN
CONTROL OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK THIS IS VALUABLE AND I
WOULD GUESS YOU MIGHT AGREE THAT
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POSITION ON
THE PRESIDENT OR ITS RALLY, THE
EFFECTIVE SUPPORT FOR FOR
AMERICANS IS THAT GOVERNMENT,
CITY GOVERNMENTS, STATE
GOVERNMENTS CAN TAKE CONTROL OF
AN ENVIRONMENT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WILL SEE,
AREN’T THEY?
>> I THINK ABSOLUTELY.
OKLAHOMA AND THE RULE OF LAW,
AND WHAT YOU WERE GOING TO SEEK
CONVERGING ON TULSA’S EVERY
MANNER OF ANARCHIST OR ANYONE
THAT IS ANTI-TRUMP, THEY WILL
SHOW UP AND THEY WILL HAVE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE THEY ARE TO DO
NOTHING BUT PROVOKE THE POLICE.
THEY ARE TRAINED TO DO IT.
I HAVE SEEN THEM DO IT.
THEY WILL SPIT ON THEM.
THEY WILL THROW ROCKS ON THEM
AND JUST COMMIT ALL KINDS OF
VIOLENCE.
>> Tammy: YOU HAVE SEEN THIS,
CHRIS, CHRIS KRISTOF THINKS WE
ARE BEING TOO ALARMIST.
THESE ANTIFA PANICS ARE WHERE
RACISM AND HYSTERIA INTERSECT.
IN A NATION THAT IS MORE GUNS
THAN PEOPLE COME UP WHEN A
PRESIDENT TAKES EVERY
OPPORTUNITY NOT TO HEAL OUR
NATION’S DIVISION BUT TO STOKE
AND WHEN PEOPLE LIVE IN --
PROVIDES NO REALITY CHECK BUT
INFLAMES PREJUDICED AND FEEDS
FEAR.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
DO YOU BUY INTO THAT?
>> NOT A BIT.
I’VE SEEN THEM IN ACTION.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SEEN THEM IN
ACTION AND UNDERSTAND THEIR
DOCTRINE, THEY WERE DOCTRINE IS
VIOLENCE CAN BE COMMITTED
AGAINST PEOPLE THEY DEEM TO BE
FASCIST.
THEIR DEFINITION OF
PROFESSIONALISM IS ANYONE ON THE
RIGHT OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
SO IF THEY FIND SOMEONE WEARING
A MAGA HAT, THEY WILL HIT THEM
WITH STICKS AND DROP THEM AT THE
DROP OF A HAT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE THEREFORE.
>> Tammy: UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
LOOKING AT A DYNAMIC WHERE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDERSTANDS.
THAT PERIMETER THAT YOU DESCRIBE
IS KEY.
AND WE HAVE SEEN DONALD TRUMP
RALLY BEFORE, THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THIS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SECURITY.
IS THERE AGAIN, AT LEAST
CERTAINLY A LINKAGE AND DO YOU
FIND LOCAL POLICE, DO THEY MIND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEING
THERE?
DO THEY MIND HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THE SECRET SERVICE?
WERE THESE DAYS IS THERE MORE OF
A BROTHERHOOD AND SISTERHOOD
COMING TOGETHER TO DEAL WITH
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE?
>> I THINK THE POLICE ARE VERY
HAPPY THAT THEY ARE THERE.
IT’S NOT SOME MAYOR’S DECISION
OR SOME GOVERNOR’S DECISION
INSIDE THAT FEDERAL PERIMETER.
IT IS UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
SECRET SERVICE.
AND THESE COPS WILL BE BACKED
UP.
THEY WILL BE FULL SUPPORT BEHIND
THEM.
THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
RESOURCES BEHIND THEM AS WELL.
>> Tammy: EXCELLENT,
EXCELLENT, CHRIS, THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE TIME PEOPLE ARE
COMPLAINING POLITICALLY IN MANY
INSTANCES ABOUT THE NATURE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT WHEN IT
COMES RIGHT DOWN TO IT, OUR
LIVES COHESION EXIST BECAUSE AT
THAT A THIN BLUE LINE, BUT IT IS
ALSO AN ANONYMOUS LINE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE KIND OF WORK THAT
GOES INTO MAKING OF ALL KINDS OF
EVENTS, RALLIES, FOOTBALL GAMES,